واذا نذهب الى شبكه مراسل العربيه حول
العالم لكي نحتفل معهم مباشره على الهواء
في صباح العربيه نرحب بيريتا سليمان من
واشنطن مراسله صباح العربيه وايضا سلطان
السلمي من جده يسعد صباحكم واهلا بكم وكل
عام وانتم بالف خير ريتا الكلمه لكي الان
يعني نريد ان نعرف كم دقيقه حتى تدق
الساعه ويحتفل الامريكيون في العام الجديد
صباح الخير نادين صباح الخير سهام كل عام
وانتم بخير نحن في الدقائق الاولى لعام
2023 هنا في واشنطن همم لحسن الحظ قبل
ساعه تقريبا توقف المطر عن الهطول ولكن
الضباب بدا يلف المكان همم حرم الكاميرا
من رصد الالعاب الناريه التي تملا سماء
واشنطن في هذه الاثناء همم دعوني اتحدث عن
طقوس الاحتفال في واشنطن هي عائليه
همم الجميع يتناول طعام العشاء في منزله
همم ثم همم يبداون بالتدفق على ضفاف نهر
بوتوماك الشهير في واشنطن حيث نتواجد الان
لمتابعه الالعاب الناريه همم في مجمل
المعالم في همم واشنطن في مختلفه المناطق
ان كان في الناشونال او حتى في همم النصف
التذكاريه العديده وما اكثرها هنا في
واشنطن همم الاجواء من من حولي كلها
عائليه حتى الاطفال
تخطوا موعد نومهم بكثير فقط لياتوا اا الى
هنا وليشاهدوا الالعاب الناريه همم في
سماء همم واشنطن لدينا الان هذه الالعاب
مستمره في هذه الاثناء امامنا وايضا من
خلفي ولكن الكاميرا لن تستطيع رصدها بسبب
الضباب الكثيف الذي بدا يلف المكان همم
هنا العائلات تحتفل وسعيده جدا حتى
الاطفال تحدوا البارد ايضا لمشاه
والاحتفال بسنه 2023 على طريقه اهالي
واشنطن على ضفاف نهر
طيب هل من شيء جديد مميز هذه السنه في
احتفالات راس السنه الميلاديه
غير انك موجوده
شكرا انها المره الاولى منذ ثلاثه اعوام
يتمكن فيها اهالي المدينه من الاحتفال ااا
قدوم العام الجديد من دون كرونه
والعوائق التي فرضتها كورونا وفرضتها ايضا
السلطات هنا لمنع همم
هذا كرونا ايضا من الانتشار بين المواطنين
همم الان همم كل كل هذه الاعاقه منعت
الجميع هنا سعيد يحتفلون همم
بقدوم هذه السنه الجديده بكثير من الفرح
وايضا نعم نعم مع عائلاتهم هنا واكيد واضح
عليك الفرح والابتسامه ويديم عليك السعاده
واتمنى ان ترتدي سنه 20 23 رداء ابيض مثل
الذي ترتديه وان يكون نعم خير علينا
وسلامه جميعا خلينا نشوف سلطان السلمي من
جده جده غير يا سلطان يسعد صباحك واحلم
ذكرى في اول يوم في العام الجديد كيف كانت
الاحتفالات في جده واليوم شو التوقعات
بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه في
العام الجديد
[موسيقى]
يا صباح الخير عليكم وعلى كافه المشاهدين
صباح العربيه ويا رب يكون عام مليئه
بالاحلام و الامنيات وتتحقق اهداف الجميع
يا رب اليوم مختلف في جده عشنا ليله
مختلفه ليله راس السنه وتحديدا في مناطق
مختلفه من السعوديه تحدثنا عن العاصمه
السعوديه الرياضه تشاهده احتفالات ضخمه في
مناطق مختلفه وتحديدا او قيمه الليل
ترابيه فنيه من طراز عالي بحضور قرابه 12
فنان عربي نتحدث بمقدمتهم همم اصاله
واليسا وراغب علامه وغيرهم من الفريق الذي
حفلا جماهيريا ضخما في البوليفارد سيتي في
الرياض ان هي كان الالعاب الناريه في جده
وفي الرياض ومختلفه في المناطق في الشرقيه
وغير المناطق السعوديه التي احتفلت بشكل
مختلف في جده لحظات مختلفه عشناها مساء
البارحه وتحديدا في همم بعد منتصف الليل
في كورنيش جده شهاده العائلات السعوديين
والسعوديات وكذلك حتى يمين نشاهد الزي
الاحمر التوزيع الورود بين المواطنين
للمقيمين او وجود الاطفال والعائلات في
الكورنيش وفي منتجعات وكذلك في المطاعم
والكافيهات التي تزينت باللون الاحمر
واقامه الحفلات الطبيه والغنائيه في مختلف
المواقع في السعوديه كان احتفال مختلف
اليوم سنه جديده السعوديه من المتوقع ان
نشهد يعني تغيرات مختلفه احداث مختلفه
نتحدث على مختلف المستويات رياضيه وثقافيه
واقتصاديا وتنمويه ليوم السعوديه المقبله
على مرحله مختلفه من المشاريع النوعيه
تحدثنا مشاريع القديه ومشاريع البحر
الاحمر ومشاريع اليوم وغيرها من المشاريع
التي سوف ترى النور في مراحل معينه خلال
مجرى هذا العامه في مناطق مختلفه من
السعوديه الحفله الحفل كان مختلف مساء
البارحه في الرياض حضور جماهيري كبير في
بعض المواقع المجمعات الترفيهيه في
السعوديه تحدثنا عن مدينه الرياض ومدينه
جده اجواء مختلفه عاش السعوديين استقبل
العام بابتسامه كبيره بامنيات باحلام يعني
طالبين الله يتم تقبلها منهم وان تكون سنه
مختلفه وسعيده على الكل نعم
جده عيد وبحر شكرا جزيلا لك السلطان
سليمان ونشكر جزيلا زميلتنا العزيزه
الغاليه يا ريتا سليمان شكرا جزيلا لكم
[موسيقى]